imagine an ocean where water is
constantly boiling
it's boundless there is no ghost inside
it stretches as far as the horizon
although this fact is evasive to the
observer because as far as the eye can
see
the horizon is constantly shrouded in
dense fog
thick clouds with not a [ __ ] between
them hide a huge but dim
sun only negligible changes and level of
light
indicate transitions from nights to days
and nights again
if it has stopped being pitch dark and
its deep gray all around you
it means sunrise and deep down
under scores of kilometers of water
there lies a billion ton core of
scorching ice
this is what the unique and mysterious
world of gliese 1214b
must look like
the first steps in theoretical
confirmation of there being ocean worlds
out there
that is planets fully covered in water
were made back in the 1970s
that is when evidence was found that
radioactive decay in a planet's interior
and tidal forces
may cause water ice to melt and
subsequently form
huge oceans in all likelihood
similar processes take place on
jupiter's and saturn's satellites
however these celestial bodies remain
icebound
as they lie too far away from the sun
whose rays would otherwise melt the
thick layers of ice
but when we talk about an ocean planet a
slightly different
type of space objects is meant the term
implies that the ocean on a planet's
surface isn't concealed under a layer of
ice
and its depth measures more than 100
kilometers
theoretical calculations of these
planets formation and evolution
processes were carried out in 2004 by
french astrophysicists headed by
christophe satan
according to this theory if the mass of
a forming planet is more than 10 times
that of the earth
this starts to actively attract hydrogen
and helium from the gas and dust cloud
around it in this manner with time it
grows into a gas giant
by contrast if this planet's mass is
just six to eight earth masses the new
planet is going to be comprised of ice
and rocks
roughly in equal measure just to compare
the mass total of all water in the
global ocean on our earth
accounts for just 0.025 percent
of the earth's total mass
in this case provided a space object's
orbit lies far from the host star
this object is going to be either an ice
giant
or a cold super earth radioactive decay
taking
place inside the core will help melt
some portion of the ice
which in its turn will help form a
subsurface ocean
but the planet's outer layers will still
remain frozen
if the planet happens to find itself in
its star's habitable zone
its outer layers will melt and spill all
over the surface
in a boundless ocean theoretical
calculations show that a planet with a
mass
six to eight times that of the earth may
have a layer of water
over a hundred kilometers thick the
pressure exerted by this amount of water
may reach
20 000 atmospheres depending on
temperature
impurities and other parameters this is
enough for some special exotic varieties
of ice to form
like ones remaining solid even at high
temperatures
in addition unlike the familiar water
ice
these modifications would be heavier
than liquid water
for example the density of ice seven
which is likely to form in these
conditions
should be around a thousand six hundred
and fifty kilos per cubic meter
this ice settles on the planet's ocean's
bottom
and forms a massive cryosphere that
envelops the more massive core
the opportunity to put these theoretical
assumptions to test
arose when a tiny and dim star was
spotted
42 light years away from the earth it
was dubbed
glieser1214 the diameter of this red
dwarf
turned out to be five times smaller than
that of the sun
with its mass just 15.7 percent that of
the sun
at the same time gliese 1214 is 300
times
dimmer than our parent star while its
surface temperature is only 3 000 kelvin
or 2700 degrees celsius
there is nothing particularly remarkable
about the star itself
to be blunt it is just another
nondescript red dwarf
that looks like any of the billions of
other stars in our galaxy
however in 2009 a solitary planet was
detected in its environs
which was dubbed gliese 1214 b
with its diameter measuring two and a
half times that of the earth
this exoplanet is just six and a half
times heavier than our home planet
straightforward calculations show the
freefall acceleration on the exoplanet's
surface to be just 91
that of the earth the average density of
glycer1214b
is approximately 1807 kilos per cubic
meter
judging by this comparatively small
value the exoplanet
cannot realistically be made up of
mostly metals and rocks
as is the case with our earth for
example but incidentally
this average density value seems to
confirm the assumption
that the astronomical body is 75 percent
water or water rice
and just 25 tracks thus it appears safe
to suggest
that this exoplanet is an ocean planet
the object lies very close to its host
star
the average distance between them
measures just around 2 million
kilometers or 0.014
astronomical units which is 75 times
smaller than that between the earth
and the sun also the orbit eccentricity
is rather high
at 0.27 slightly more than that of pluto
this means that in its perihelion
glieser 1214b
is approximately twice as close to its
star than when in its aphelion
as for its orbital period it takes the
planet about 36 hours to complete it
the red dwarf glieser 1214 may be 300
times dimmer than the sun
but this incredible proximity to the
star makes the climate on gliese 1214b
scorching hot supposing the reflection
coefficient of the surface of glieser
1214b
is the same as that of venus the
planet's surface temperature is supposed
to be around
393 kelvin or 120 degrees celsius
if on the other hand the surface is
darker the temperature may reach as much
as 553 kelvin
or 280 degrees celsius
due to the fact that the orbit of
glieser 1214b
crosses the star's disk scientists are
able to carry out spectroscopic
investigations of its atmosphere
still the results are rather ambiguous
if this space
object really is an ocean planet its
atmosphere is supposed to predominantly
consist of water vapor with some
accompanying gases
interestingly no lines of hydrogen
helium
or complex substances like water co2 and
ammonia have so far been detected in the
planet's spectrum
it is thought that the outer layer of
the dense atmosphere conceals its true
content from the observer
the conditions on the surface of gliese
1214b
remind one of what it is like inside a
giant steam boiler
interestingly the atmospheric pressure
in its lowest strata should be at least
15 times as high as that of the earth
as the ocean and the atmosphere are in a
state of thermodynamic equilibrium
the border between them is rather
blurred no wonder
as the density of water vapor just above
the ocean's surface
is practically equal to that of
constantly boiling water
as we look deeper at the lowest strata
of the ocean the pressure will continue
to increase
until we reach the depth of a hundred
kilometers
with a pressure value of this depth
water will be unable to remain in its
liquid state
even at temperatures this high and so we
will see the bottom made up of dense
and heavy ice whose thickness is
estimated to be upwards of 5
000 kilometers thus most water on the
planet
is concentrated here below the
cryosphere
there should be the core made up of
rocks and metals
unfortunately chances of life evolving
on any ocean planet
are rather thin even if the surface
temperature happens to be more favorable
than on this one
this is so due to the fact that oceans
on planets like that
are too poor in terms of microelements
that are vital for living creatures
even taking into account meteorites that
occasionally bombard the surfaces of
these celestial bodies
the chemical diversity is simply not
good enough for life to originate here
still studying ocean planets poses a
great scientific interest
according to nasa's mathematical
modeling estimates published in 2020
there may be billions of planets of this
type in our galaxy
both cold harboring an ocean under an
ice shell
and warm like gliese 1214b
water is one of the most widespread
complex chemical compounds in the
universe
and this means that the chances of
discovering new ocean planets
are quite optimistic meanwhile
feel free to hit the like button and
subscribe if you still haven't done so
your support greatly boosts our
motivation and inspires us to make new
interesting and informative videos let's
keep in touch
[Music]
[Music]
you